[Music]
joining me today is an author the
political editor of townhall calm and a
Fox News contributor
guidance and welcome through the report
thanks for having me this is great I am
looking forward to talking to you but
we've got to say first Fox News
contributor a certain amount of people
are going to hate you already right out
of the gate what do you do with that
kind of information well I think it's
interesting how some people use labels
as a substitute for argument so I'll
make a point on Twitter for example and
someone on the left will check my bio
and just respond
oh well Fox News contributor as if that
means anything if that's a response to
anything that I've actually argued and
I'll say good point you know like where
are you going with that and usually they
sort of scuttle off somewhere but I'm
very happy to work there I've been proud
to work there for four years it's a
great platform and one thing that
sometimes people ask me about it is you
know there's elements that are very Pro
Trump and others that aren't and are you
ever told or encouraged to think
something or say something on the air
and the answer hand to heart is no never
which I value greatly and I think if
that were different I would probably not
want to stick around and that's never
happened full editorial independence
which is I think crucial for a thriving
Network and I've been afforded that yeah
and I will back you on that much I
haven't done as much Fox's stuff as you
have but I had been on O'Reilly I've
done Tucker I've done gut selves they
let you go on and say whatever you want
the chips will fall where they may
but in terms of editing you know a lot
of this stuff is live and it kind of is
what it is but people all just have a
feeling that somehow there's something
evil or that there's an editorial line
that we somehow get a memo at the
beginning of every day here's what we
think about this today I mean it's it's
ludicrous and just look at the people I
think a lot of the critics of Fox don't
watch Fox they see short clips of it on
The Daily Show or on Samantha bee or
whatever highlighting a particularly
preposterous moment and they say well it
must be that 24/7
that's not how it is and sometimes when
people are really skeptical or cynical
about the network I'll encourage them to
watch bret baier show special report and
I say give that a shot for a week watch
2 or 3 episodes and then come back to me
and let me know if you have the exact
same perception of Fox new they ever do
it but they're very rarely pretty Center
that guy I'm sorry they do and they're
like alright this is this is a legit
show I'm like okay this is progress
that's that's a small amount of thank
you for watching yeah alright so we're
going to talk a lot about your book
ended discussion we met briefly about
two years ago in the after party at Real
Time with Bill Maher and the hardcover
had come out the softcover which we have
right here just came out so before we
get into the book though your game and a
court are we breaking this news on on
the Rubin report says it right there
doesn't well the card can't be wrong
yeah I mean this is a blue card with
typing on it yeah on the television or
whatever wherever we're sending this out
to something yes you're gay and you're a
Republican yeah well I just dropped my
cards because of it how could this
possibly be I would consider myself more
of a conservative than a Republican okay
I tend to vote Republican because the
Democratic Party to me is a completely
inhospitable place for me based on my
beliefs in my worldview but the party
the Republican Party frustrates me
deeply on a frequent basis so I feel
like I'm less attached to the are label
than I am to the conservative one but so
let's do that part first actually then
what so tell me what does being a
conservative mean to you then we'll get
to this sure we'll get to the gay stuff
Tim have great to me it just means that
I believe fundamentally that the
government especially the federal
government isn't particularly good at
doing very many things at all and they
do too many things and they do them
badly a great expense to all of us and I
think they should do fewer things do
them better and preferably the things
that they are required to do under the
Constitution and not a constantly
expanding array of tasks that they
accumulate and it cost a lot of us a lot
of money so a small government
conservative is sort of
where I come from foreign policy I'm
somewhere in the middle of the Party or
the conservative movement I'm not a
hardcore hawk but I'm not a non
interventionalist either our non
interventionist and on social issues
it's just a complete mixed bag it's hard
to pin me down rogue a marriage pro-life
sort of all over the map and given that
panoply of issues and I look at where
the parties stand you know or
where the movements are in this country
I do agree with the left on some things
but it's just outweighed by the right on
most issues I lean to the right and
therefore I tend to vote Republican
yeah so by conventional thinking though
people would say wait a minute you can't
be a gay conservative how could you have
fought for gay marriage for example from
a conservative perspective how do you
answer something like that I just think
it's a completely false premise the idea
that someone has to prioritize their
politics based on their identity I think
is a toxic corrosive leftie construct
that I just completely reject right if I
want to be a gay person who's against
gay marriage I have every right to think
that way I happen to support gay
marriage I hope you get married but and
there are some of those that exist by
them yeah there they're out there for
sure and if that's you know let's have
that discussion I'm not going to call
you self-hating because you don't
support every single one of the agenda
items of a political party or a
political movement or the LGBT community
or whatever it might be to me I look at
my priorities in terms of the elements
on policy that animate me that I think
about the most that I am concerned about
the most and if I sort of weigh them it
tilts in the rightward direction which
is why I am a conservative that doesn't
mean that I think the Republican Party
represents me perfectly or even
particularly well on gay rights issues I
also think it's an odd
it's an odd vantage point or an odd
demand that some people on the Left try
to make that if you are a sir
way if you're in a certain column or a
category of people you have to then vote
for a certain party or what have you
would you prefer that there is nobody on
the other side of the aisle making
arguments to perhaps modernize the
platform for example the Republican
Party or to introduce the idea there are
gay people that are not all that scary I
mean in this process of being on the
book tour for two years and speaking to
a lot of conservative audiences I have
been really struck by just the kindness
and the sweetness that I've encountered
from a lot of traditional conservatives
who are not necessarily even on board
for gay marriage but are sort of like oh
maybe maybe we're we're sort of
rethinking some of this a little bit one
story that comes to mind in particular
that I enjoy telling was I was at an
event in Denver a year and a half ago
maybe and we were doing a book signing
this was the hardcover back then and
fortunately there is a long line so
people were coming up and they're
wanting photos and that sort of thing
and there's this woman it was probably
in her 60s and she approached me and she
got the book signed and she was I could
tell she wanted to say something else
and she didn't know if to say or how to
say it and finally she just sort of
blurted it out whisper a little juice I
have a nephew who's the way you are and
it was it was just this very cute way of
sort of trying to just say you know and
I love him
yeah and that was her way of trying to
communicate about it and just sort of
Pat me on the shoulder and say you're
welcome you're welcome here and you know
we've got your back and there's been
some of that and frankly my favorite
response that I've gotten from
conservatives since I came out in the
book actually yeah years ago so the
timing was all I mean you did this sort
of in lockstep well and I can explain
that in a second but I was just going to
say my favorite response has been
ambivalence people just being like noted
moving on right that's the best response
to me because the reason that I didn't
come out publicly sooner is because
I felt like it was no one's business
mm-hmm this is my personal life anyone
who knew me closely my family my friends
my colleagues they all knew yeah I just
wasn't publicly gay because I didn't
want to pigeonhole myself right out of
the gate in my career as the gay
whatever I wanted people to start to
read my work see me on TV and get a
sense of you know the content of what I
put out rather than viewing me through
an identity lens immediately but because
we delve into some of these issues gay
rights and religious liberty and so on
in an entire chapter of the book
entitled bake me a cake bigots I felt
like at that point if I'm going to write
10,000 words on an issue I should
probably disclose just journalistically
that I'm gay so I did it in a footnote
in the book and I felt it was the right
time for the right reason yeah so when
you go on the tour and and you're
meeting now these conservatives and
you're doing book signings and things
like that and most of them don't care do
you think that's the best way to
actually change people's minds I know at
all you did you put in a footnote okay
now here I am let's go ahead you get any
blowback a little bit but it was like
hurting legit people I mean maybe from
some haters on Twitter but were there
any because I get this all the time
because people because I think we're
going to agree on the on the cake I'm
pretty sure we have a gay cake thing and
I'll say well people you know people say
to me well see you're tolerating the
these Republicans who hated you all
these years I'm like well they've
changed a lot actually there's been a
huge sea change I also don't accept that
someone having a political disagreement
or not wanting to participate in a gay
wedding it quoits to hating me um so I
try to be more generous in spirit on
that sort of thing but you're also
allowed to hate people
I mean you are it doesn't have kind of
uncomfortable we don't like it I do
encourage that I don't encourage it I
would rather not have it but you are
even for bad reasons you are allowed to
date you're not allowed to hurt people
right you know physically but you are
allowed to have your own bigoted views
it's just how it is yeah but I think I'd
like to change those views but and
that's part of I think what you do right
that's just doing the show and reaching
out to new especially younger audiences
they're sort of like Oh
open people's minds in the society where
we seem to be trending in the other
direction the wrong direction but your
question reminds me of another stop on
the tour this one was in New Mexico I
believe and my co-authors Mary Katharine
ham is like a very very dear friend
we've been almost like siblings at this
point and she's at CNN now so we were in
in Albuquerque and during the Q&A we had
done our normal spiel about the book and
someone asked her it had just been
remember the day without women yep where
there's a strike to show the impact of
women in society so a woman asked her
during the session how did you spend
your day without women and then I think
she thought like oh I should maybe just
ask guy anyway because I don't want to
only ask a question of Mary Katherine
so the Mary Katherine gave this great
answer about the day without women and
she was very charming and very funny
and then she tossed it to me she's like
well what did you do with your day
without women I'm like that's sort of
everyday for me right and I in my mind I
was like is this a joke that I should
make like just a straight-up
self-deprecating gay joke in front of a
an older conservative audience got a
huge laugh sort of punctured any
awkwardness about that and it was like
done yeah most people don't care which
is definitely progress and that's also
why you know just to have you here and
have this conversation people don't get
this kind of conversation too often
between two gay people that come from
things from a slightly different
political perspective right but I know
when I've had Milo here who you know
comes from a completely other political
I got it even in this chair he's been in
that very it wasn't in this room but
he's been in that very chair okay which
will now taint you I'm sure in some way
that you'll never be able to you know
have to come back and I'll leave that
one uh but but point being that people
that would we've talked even though we
come from things from a different
perspective also that it's refreshing
for people to hear gay people talk about
issues that are just about fashion or
whatever the things that Bravo is
telling you yeah all gay people should
care about
that's so this is actually a story that
I've never told but when I in
processing like every gay person has
gone through the process of coming out
and like the first step is coming out to
yourself right and then you sort of for
me I expanded the circle of trust so to
speak and one of the conversations that
I was most dreading was with a very
close group of guy friends from college
went to Northwestern and we were all at
a bachelor party weekend in Montreal for
one you know one of our buddies is
getting married and I just sort of felt
this was the time we were all together
yeah so I told them and they sort of
were shocked and they interrogated me
for an hour in the hotel like what do
you mean and I could sort of get the
sense from the line of questioning a
little bit they were like so the person
that we've gotten to know like is that
all real or all fake or what's going on
I'm like you know like I'm the
conservative Christian sports fan let
them know yeah I just happen to like
dudes like that's the only thing that
are different because there is this
stereotype of what we are supposed to
like or dislike or and as I have sort of
grown into being gay you start to meet
more gay people and you're sort of like
oh these stereotypes are beyond yeah
they're silly some of them I mean some
of them are fair but a lot of them are
silly and I think now that it's more
we're in a more tolerant and open
society gay gay people LGBT Q people
come in all shapes and sizes and I'm
hoping that's becoming not just more
mainstream for average America but also
within the gay club there's a little bit
more openness to some diversity at least
that's my aspiration here interesting
because my next question was sort of
going to be the reverse of that which is
that right now I see the gay community I
see two things happening and they're
happening at the exact same time sort of
in parallel with each other one I see a
community that used to be really
irreverent and fun and over the top and
drag queens and any politically
incorrect joke and all I see
that's starting to crumble because of
some of the stuff that you talk about in
this book about the political
correctness now steeping and so the
people who used to be the outsiders are
now sort of the insiders and they're
becoming politically correct but then I
also at the same time I see because of
that that I see a certain amount of gay
people are starting to shift away from
leftism because they're going wait a
minute this isn't fun anymore or
something like they've taken away
something very special that the gay
community had do you see that yeah
although I think probably some of it is
just a backlash to political correctness
and that's by no means exclusive to the
gay community right I think part of the
reason we have the president that we
have is because people got so tired of
this stifling weaponized political
correctness from the left that
eventually a lot of people on the right
said we've had enough if they're going
to bully us culturally endlessly we're
going to go hire our own bully and it is
his orange and we're going to hire them
and that's that's who we have I think a
lot of this is a cultural backlash and
that of course extends to you know a
certain number of gay people as well and
there's also just lots of good reasons
to be a conservative if you're a
taxpayer I don't care what your sexual
orientation is if you think the
government is taking too much of the
money that you earn if you think the
military should be strong and defeat our
enemies if you believe like I do in the
pro-life cause there's lots of different
reasons why someone can end up within
the conservative movement I do think
that for people who are LGBT the
Republican Party's platform and a lot of
their rhetoric especially in the past
has been a barrier to entry which I
completely understand
I think the rhetoric and the toleration
is getting better it's by no means
perfect but it's getting better and I
think it's also a generational shift in
a lot of ways yeah I mean interestingly
Trump is the first president that ever
came in on a first term basically being
for Pro you know Pro gay marriage right
I mean or did Obama the first time where
he just doesn't care I mean Peter Thiel
spoke at the at the convention Trump the
week before the election was on stage
with a rainbow flag again I have no idea
what he thinks about Gabriel I just
don't think he thinks it's an issue and
I think that that has
sort of just trickle down to people
where they're just like big damn what
yeah I mean he's done some things as
president I know really inflamed the gay
community but overall I think it is and
I'm as you know I'm not a huge fan
you're a president all the time I try to
be fair to him and one of the things
that I think is you have to say is
indisputably he's the most Pro LGBT
Republican president ever it's not even
close the fact that he had a gay
supporter on stage at the RNC talking
about being gay and being proud of being
gay and getting a standing ovation like
that's unheard of even rewinding the
clock for five ten years for sure so and
you know he's asked about gay marriage
he's like I'm fine with it
and if you look at public polling
there's been heavy movement on same-sex
marriage in terms of public opinion
particularly among self-identified
Republicans and I do think that probably
Trump has helped give some people sort
of a mental permission slit to be like
Oh like well we like Trump and he
doesn't seem to care about this maybe
we've got bigger fish to fry maybe maybe
I don't okay with this now so do you
think the anti-gay stuff for the
Republicans you know we can sort of
parse down where it eventually came from
and did Karl Rove use it as a wedge
issue with george w bush or any of sf'
but that there was an odd alliance
between the christian conservatives that
we're going to be socially conservative
versus the small government republicans
and I sense you're sort of both of those
but that that Alliance didn't fully make
sense because Republicans should have I
think taking them they could have taken
a moral stance on how government should
operate and said we we shouldn't be
involved in this and how two people want
to you know go about a private relation
it's probably got a leg they just got
crushed into this thing that Tyrion and
I think the label of socially
conservative is a tricky one especially
for our generation and younger people
because if you look at a lot of the
public polling data and we talked about
this in end of discussion
throughout much of the modern era of
American pundit Rhee people talk about
social issues they're really talking
about two
talking about abortion and gay rights
and there's been this lazy assumption
that they're a package deal and people
who you can you can predict what someone
will believe about one issue based on
what they believe about the other let me
pause you there for a second because I'm
Pro gay marriage obviously not only my
program marriage I married to do that
that's very proud that's very Pro really
on the record very very pro but I but I
am pro-choice but grudgingly as I say
every time and you're Pro gay marriage
not married so we'll see if you really
put it into action but but you're
pro-life but that's the point so it
doesn't always work and it and if you
look at the polling data for younger
people we have moved heavily to the left
or the libertarian direction on gay
rights but are really the most pro-life
generation aside from senior citizens we
are more pro-life than Xers we are more
pro-life than boomers and so these are
not a package deal they're not linked
together and I think I've thought a lot
about this and I think some of it comes
down to the argument about fairness and
people's rights I think the right or the
anti gay marriage right really got its
clock cleaned
when it came to explain to people why
gay marriage is really a problem
who is that harming go and the arguments
are weak and I used to I used to believe
except sort of a lockstep conservative I
checked all the boxes and then you start
you know in college I started to think
critically about stuff I'm like okay
well here I am making these arguments
they suck
like I know they suck I'm going to keep
making them and it's sort of like all
right I can't I have to abandon them
yeah um there isn't a concrete victim to
gay marriage that is persuasive to the
American people whereas on abortion I
think you can make an ethical scientific
moral case that there is clearly of a
wrong pictum party in an abortion that
people are willing to listen to that and
at least think about it whereas with gay
marriage like well my brother's gay my
friend is gay my you know cousins a
lesbian what are you talking about yeah
um I think that's part it's the paradigm
of human
that I think makes these issues diverge
for a lot of young people yeah so my
audience knows that as we air this I am
off the grid completely so this is an
airing this is airing a couple weeks
after I've been gone so I'm trying not
to do too much topical stuff okay but as
we're taping this right now we're in the
middle of this thing with the Trump's
ban on trans people in the military I
think because we're both gay that people
probably want to get some answers out of
us and I always think it's kind of funny
you know when they put these letters
together LGBT I have no more inherent
knowledge of what it's like to be a
trans person than a straight person but
I does by default so first you agree
with that premise that you as a gay
person don't have any sort of innate
knowledge of trans issues just on its
face yes although the one thing I would
push back on is there's probably a
little bit more empathy because I think
equity I think there's a lot of people
in America who really have trouble
wrapping their mind around same-sex
attraction generally it's not something
that they've ever experienced or like
that's just I don't understand how
someone could be like that I think
that's also true for even more people
when it comes to trans folks and so
that's where the empathy I think for me
exists even though I am by no stretch an
expert I'm not even sure if I'm getting
the pronouns right there are so many
rules so yeah like and we get we have to
get into it or we had a little
subsection called transgressions where
we go through how speaking incorrectly
with the wrong terms or problematically
got people like you know Katie Couric in
trouble and then Dan Savage in trouble
and then to top it all off RuPaul we've
got in trouble I'm like we are through
the freakin looking-glass RuPaul is now
transphobic or whatever you know the the
epithet is and I don't think sometimes
the trans community or the LGBTQ
community does itself a great service by
getting reflexively offended by people
using words or
in question is just trying to figure
things out and learn yeah
well that sort of hysteria and that sort
of men lack of sense of humor too is
also goes to what I was saying before
about why I see gay people sort of
shifting to the center or even to the
right now because they've just kind of
had it with that and it reminds me that
when we met two years ago very briefly
as I said it was a Bill Maher and even
since then by using a word he got in
trouble by the left even though no one
in their right mind thinks that Bill
Maher is a racist
[Music]
you